*risate*
no, sono shockata... Questa non si può mettere
ciao ragazzi ,come vi avevo promesso è arrivato il famoso video dei diari wooooW
Prima di partire con il video volevo salutare 3 di voi e alla fine del video troverete le istruzioni per farvi salutare
nel prossimo video allora oggi saluterò Evelin_pavese_16
Chiaravarisco_ e
gaia_loves_nutellah
Siccome in tanti mi avete chiesto marina visto che ci hai detto che hai ancora I tuoi vecchi diari
Leggili insieme a noi ed è arrivato finalmente il momento di aprire
insieme a voi  I diari di prima seconda terza media ma soprattutto il capolavoro della prima liceo
partiamo dalle medie allora il diario della prima prima media è un diario sobrio stranamente innanzitutto, I siti da non perdere canale 5
Britney Spears
molto bene questi sono i siti da non perdere passiamo alla parte filosofica con queste
Due frasi che sono tratte da un libro di poesie. Del novecento ed è "la vita è come la scala
Del pollaio breve ma piena di m*rda" oppure "La vita è come un albero di natale
Tutti ti rompono le p*lle" eeee
delle dediche anche "marina marina marina cosa potrei dirti se non
che sei una ragazza un po' birichina ma non importa"
una bella dedica
sicuramente era un'amica e
"riusciranno i nostri eroi a farla franca sarà o sarà franca a farsi i nostri eroi" dei compagni di classe molto simpatici passiamo al
allora c'erano delle pagine dedicate a san valentino quindi il titolo della pagina era "pensieri stupendi" dove ogni ragazzina ovviamente
riversava il proprio romanticismo la propria voglia di un amore forte
Nelle parole che trovava più adatte queste sono quelle che ho riversato io su questo foglio
"se lui che mi sta vicino fosse bello
io gli direi
Fammi il regalo di san valentino
o ti tiro un pugno
nelle parti basse"
Emmm
bene
"L'amore è l'apostrofo rosa sulla parola cuore peccato che l'accento si posa sulla parola
muore"
C'era dell'ottimismo e ma continuiamo subito
"Quando venezia non avrà più il mare ti potrò dimenticare"
questo è un po più soft se cupido da un cuore cadrà io lo aiuterò chiedendogli lei in cambio che cosa mi dà
L'amore, dell'uomo. Più bello del mondo
E io risposi ho capito è flavio. Del grande fratello chiaramente
Chiaramente era lui. L'amore deriva della parola amo peccato che non
abbocchi, con i pesciolini che sono lì con l'amo sopra di loro
molto artistica allora
Ovviamente non lo sapete ve lo dico io
Ero la regina delle feste di Halloween tutti tutti gli halloween la festa di halloween della classe si
svolgeva a casa mia quindi
nella sezione dedicata ad halloween
feci un comunicato stampa
per appunto annunciare
questa mia festa
Mercoledì 31 ottobre alle 9 di sera incomincerà la mia festa di halloween gli invitati sono Giuditta
Jennifer,Elisa e naturalmente io
Quindi è un 3 più uno 4 invitati, dopo resteranno a dormire ho addobbato con festoni di ogni genere zucche fantasmi
fantasmi scheletri
Vorrei invitare qualcun altro ma tutti vanno a fare le vacanze perché c'è il ponte
ok sono indecisa su chi invitare
alla fine eravamo rimasti in quattro è stata una bella festa
ehh
si
a bella questa queste sono delle dediche per I ragazzi
Se I ragazzi brutti fossero fiori stupendi. La mia classe sarebbe uno dei giardini più belli del mondo
I ragazzi sono come I bagni : sempre occupati
sei i brutti ragazzi fossero granelli di sabbia la mia scuola sarebbe un deserto
Se un ragazzo ti molla e grida all' america capirà che siete stati uniti così si USA
Essa è un gioco di parole ragazze un altro livello. Ad agosto
Come sapete le pagine delle vacanze estive vengono riempite di dediche cose varie
Scrivevo vedo il sole e vedo te
vedo la luna e vedo te
vedo il mare e vedo te per favore spostati ecco
bellissima questa dedica
Non voglio oro non voglio argento voglio te al cento per cento
e che carina
Il treno fischia, il vento tace scordarmi di te non sono capace quindi c'era già ero
Già diventata più dolce in questi ultimi giorni di scuola. se vedi una ciabatta ricordati di un'amica matta
chiaramente
ciabatta amica matta
comunque avevo dei problemi seri raga, la scuola è come la luce della vita vuoi un consiglio resta al buio
Qui il testo di shakira whenever wherever che io adoravo, soprattutto il video lei che saliva fuori dall'acqua tutto quel momento di bacino altro che belly
Dance di musically di quella quella l'esordio. Della belly dancing, shakira. seconda media
Seconda media sempre con quel mood rosa siti da non perdere
www.sarannofamosi.it il mio sogno era andare a saranno famosi. I miei miti
Discoteche cioè io scrivevo le discoteche dove andava mia sorella
Fingendo che fossero le discoteche dove andavo a ballare io, capito facevo la seconda media ovviamente non andavo in discoteca. comunque c'erano tutti i locali
Dove mia sorella andava il sabato sera, io per farmi la figa li scrivevo, non si sa mai che qualcuno pensasse che io comunque andavo in discoteca
Serie tv del cuore beautiful centovetrine
Streghe e sabrina
E cuore rubati che non mi ricordo che cos'era adesso ma dev'essere una cosa trashissima
ma andiamo avanti
Io e la matematica abbiamo avuto sempre un bel rapporto, matematica
sufficiente è molto incerta nei calcoli e nel collegare le informazioni praticamente mi stava dando della cretina
Tutte le insegnanti di matematica che ho avuto la mia vita mi odiavano. alle medie, al liceo
e anche alle elementari
Quindi la matematica l'ho sempre odiata, non ho capito se io odiavo la matematica oppure
Il fatto che loro mi odiassero e mi facevano odiare la matematica comunque io e la matematica non abbiamo mai avuto un bel rapporto ma andiamo avanti perché ci sono altre note
Di questa signora di cui non dico il nome
Ma lei sa chi è
vero alberta
Sempre la nostra amica prof l'insegnante di matematica sei sempre tu lo sai, non ha svolto tutti gli esercizi
Allora era il caso di scrivere una nota cioè tutti ogni tanto non facciamo gli esercizi non mi sembra giusto questa ce l'aveva con me ragazzi
Ce l'aveva con me
Educazione artistica allora io ho sempre mi sono sempre chiesta i voti no delle medie ultime questi quasi buono più che buono
addirittura qui
benino
Che cosa vuol dire benino cioè veramente dove se li inventano questi voti bene benino più che buono ottimo
meno
nella stessa pagina della prima media
Ho scritto ho fatto una bellissima festa di halloween con tanto di addobbi abbiamo guardato scary movie 2 e ci siamo divertiti
Io mi sono vestita da strega
E mi sono messa dei tacchi altissimi che bello ah lui
Passiamo alla terza media la terza media una versione un po minimal il diario della terza media è molto minimal
C'è una banconota da 500 euro
Sicuramente vera qua dentro e una cartolina di david beckham
trasformato in una dolce
signorina ma soprattutto è caduto un free drink
Forse questo è il segno che in terza media sono anche la mia prima festa sicuramente sarà stata pomeridiana
è comunque un drink in caso ce l'ho ancora. troviamo un bigliettino
qua nella pagina c'è scritto Britney, Britney spearse era il mio primo idolo, scrivevo Britney ovunque, poi affianco c'è scritto open
with caution please
Che cosa ci sarà dentro un segreto
Io ero innamorata di tom welling
Infatti come potete notare era anche nel nel retro del diario
Sempre lui io innamorata di ascanio
Del grande fratello oltre a tom welling in terza media avevo attaccato la foto come potete vedere gli avevo scritto
ascanio
lascia perdere katia sono meglio io chiaramente allora lui dento la casa del grande fratello, si è
fidanzato con katia che adesso dopo dieci anni è ancora sua moglie, ci ha già avuto figli, famiglia ecc
ma io comunque ero meglio doveva scegliere me
Quando è stato eliminato, dalla casa di grande fratello io sono andata a scuola e piangevo perché ero disperata da questa notizia
Io non vedo l'ora di andare in provenza solo che sei ore di viaggio da un po lunghe che palle a me vengono in gita
che culo
Tu non ne avrai già più
questi erano discorso importanti
Spero tanto di stare in stanza con te sono contentissimo noi non abbiamo inglese
E proprio carino il costume. Del saggio il bianco però è il colore più carino ma rinuncia c'è un problema
Ho paura che mi voglio oggi puoi venire da me tanto per domani non abbiamo compiti mari scappo che ti voglio bene ma, non
ho più voglia di scrivere
Ha studiato per circa due ore altre materie durante educazione artistica
Ragazze non si fa. durante il compito ha usato la calcolatrice nascosta nel portapenne ed era sempre lei era sempre lei la prof
Non vi sembra strano che  è sempre le note me
Si distrae durante le lezioni c'è addirittura un giorno dopo l'altro ragazzi ma
c'è questa s'era fissata. Deve essere più sicura è geometria, un'altra nota
Che non sai dove sei più sicura ma  passiamo al 16 luglio, la data del mio compleanno happy birthday to me
14 14 anni l'età giusta per
Un nuovo cellulare
il motorino che non ho mai visto
e molto altro, molto bene dopo aver
Dopo aver visto con voi diari delle medie passiamo al diario che secondo me ci regalerà più emozioni tutti ed è il diario
Della prima liceo voi soprattutto vi chiederete perché maria via attaccato dell'edera dietro il diario? non
Lo so è un diario che ho paura di aprire un diario che
Spesso pieno di roba e sembra tutto tranne che un diario scolastico
Non so come mi abbiano permesso a scuola deve così allora apriamo il diario
Ci sono subito delle citazioni di 3 metri sopra il cielo ci sono due giorni a cui non. Penso mai e ieri e domani
Da tre metri sopra il cielo questa è una citazione importantissima niente è un film che comunque ha
Segnato tutte noi negli anni 90 ragazze del 2000 se non l'avete mai visto guardate tre metri sopra il cielo perché ha fatto
la storia poi andando avanti
troviamo questa foto
non so se ora
e secondo me non esistono commenti si commenta da sola e
Lo lascerei così interpretabile, ah che bello questa è la foto di una giraffa
Dove l'ho fatta? non lo so, una foto di leoni anche qui sarà andato ad uno zoo perché ho leoni, giraffe e  coccodrilli, un po' di tutto
Qua iniziano, i bigliettini ragazzi l'amore
qua ci sono delle dichiarazioni
importanti
cià cara marina io vorrei chiederti una cosa molto importante per me voglio chiederti se vuoi farti una storia con me
quando ti guardo mi fa impazzire
sei troppo figa mandami una risp nel secondo intervallo i love you
Sono scioccata ma c'è un altro bigliettino
Cara marina ho saputo che adesso sei rimasta single o tipo se rimasta vedova sei rimasta single vorrei sapere se tu vorresti metterti con me
rispondi tra virgolette per favore quindi anche in maniera gentile ed educata
Ma ce n'è un'altra sempre la stessa ragazza che a quanto pare era fissato
Mai mi potrò dimenticare il giorno in cui ti ho vista dal primo momento mi sei
piaciuta non riesco a pensare a nient'altro che a te mi piace il tuo modo di fare e non mi importa di quello che
Pensano gli altri di me perché io ti amo e non smetterò mai
Di pensarlo ormai mi hai fatto innamorare di te, per me tu sei la persona più importante del mondo quindi sono giunto alla conclusione
Marina tu mi piaci troppo perciò ti metteresti con me so che sei fidanzata però non mi stancherò mai richiede
Qui c'è un primo selfie allora avete presente belen quando arrivare foto facendo finta di non. Guardare obiettivo cioè
No, se le fa solo. Bene ci facciamo un po tutto però diciamo che fa abbastanza ridere il mood di fare
Le foto facendo finta che non ti stai facendo una foto
Anche se non c'era di cellulare c'era né macchinette digitali
Io l'avevo fatta avevo posato la macchinetta
Su uno scaffale e ho fatto finta come se fossi lì in camera a guardare il vuoto e qualcome qualcuno mi fotografasse ecco
Perché sabato io elo cicci mamy judy abbiamo visto sto
Di film che non faceva  un di paura
Carina nella recensione top comunque mymovies direttamente. poi messaggio per gli insostenibili adulti
Adulti poveri adulti non ragionate più. La vostra mente pensa solo al denaro al lavoro allo shopping
Allo sport non avete l'animo gioviale di
Noi ragazzi che non ci vergogniamo se per 2 giorni siamo vestiti uguali o se la scuola prendiamo brutti voti invece voi cadete
Dalle nuvole se vi licenziano
E poi soprattutto le donne sempre lì a truccarsi
Cambiarsi andare dal parrucchiere ragazze sono io questa
E fare le oche non. È che non sono credo che I parrucchieri dovrebbero essere aboliti presto no be ragazzi sto decollando
Non sopporto le donne con mille mesh e le parrucche
Ci sono donne che vivono di telenovele ma questo non. Le contesto perché lo faccio, anch'io
un messaggio per gli adulti non pensate solo a voi guardatevi intorno alla natura
Gli animali e le altre persone che ci circondano unitevi e formato una popolazione adulta che vive in pace e segue le orme
cristiane
Non si capiva quale
la mia mentalità
Perché in verità se tutti possiamo veramente cristiani nel mondo non ci sarebbero guerre e catastrofi un consiglio rifletteteci su che non abbiate paura di
Abbassarvi a seguire I consigli dei giovani
Bene dopo di ciò sono diventata presidente degli stati uniti ma passerei alla scheda tecnica del mio primo fidanzatino
avevo questa fissa ogni volta mi piaceva qualcuno di fare una scheda tecnica proprio nome e cognome
capelli colore occhi e bla bla bla
fisico e la nostra canzone primo bacio e ultimo bacio ai durato per 2 3
Mi sono rotta ovviamente. Le palle era una cosa un po ridicola però apparire la prima scheda tecnica
Ovviamente I dati persone lo ridico capelli castani occhi castani
bellezza il voto della bellezza 6
Simpatie 8 più e già li puzzava un po di friendzone
durata storia nove giorni
Una storiona e
Anche le date primo bacio e ultimo bacio ma soprattutto una cosa su cui riflettere molto è fisico muscoloso
tra parentesi
Relativamente allora non, si sa perché marina si sia messo questo ragazzo è stata una storia comunque importante durata
Nove giorni e la bellezza da sei quindi
facciamoci due domande praticamente non esisteva la parola friendzone ma io già la percepivo nell'area vi
Ho già capito tutto ancora nascere quella parola è così giunti al termine
Del video spero tanto che mi sia piaciuto mi raccomando se volete essere salutati. Nel prossimo video dovete semplicemente
seguirmi su instagram inviarmi un bel direct  con scritto il vostro nome e
Mi puoi salutare sul prossimo video e aspettare ovviamente il prossimo video su youtube per vedere se siete stati tra. I tre fortunati ad essere
Salutati sei video vi è piaciuto come al solito lasciate un commento e mettetevi un bel like e ovviamente se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi al canale ricordatevi anche di seguirmi sugli altri social
instagram facebook e music e ad ora